hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the dreadout
demo dread ouch now this is just a demo
but this game is supposed to be like
fatal frame of which I have not played
so here we go
clatter ski my name is Mauro caps locks
markiplier hi the music is quite loud to
me is that my vibrator going off again
oh no this looks really nice this is an
indie game and the the demo is free but
this looks almost professionally done in
fact this does look professionally done
so I am obviously a woman
and I'm looking for a phone that's going
off or at least I hope it's a phone okay
well yeah this actually looks really
impressive Oh God inverted controls are
you kidding me Oh God
whoever plays inverted controls is
obviously a communist I'll get used to
it
hello oh wait it wasn't inverted
controls it was just walking oh no what
is he okay that was weird
why was hahahahahahaha what the hell was
that I've actually I hadn't actually
heard of this game and I thought I would
have heard of it like a while ago but oh
man that was freaky okay in fatal frame
so I've heard that you look through you
look for ghosts through a camera and I
guess it's kind of the same principle
here but whatever the hell that was I
think I want to look through the camera
thank you very much okay I don't know if
this is like Japan or some else
yeah the controls aren't inverted or
they seemed inverted at first but
I don't know everything seems to be
better now I hear noises but I don't see
a door or anything
yeah there's no door it's just kind of
here is there a door I just am I just
too dumb to see it it's staring me right
in front of my face but I cannot see it
I hear noises coming from here so I said
dealio huh there's no way out of here
oh come on it was right there how big of
an idiot am i I'm a I'm a giant idiot
hi I'm gonna go this way
are you my friend you want to be friends
you want to be we're not friends are we
it got darker it's got a lot darker
why why why did that happen oh boy
ah ah alright so anyway let me just try
to keep my cool here this is like the
first different I haven't played a game
like this before so this is all very new
to me and it's really dark I cannot see
anything down that hall
I mean I'm actually excited because you
know this is actually original compared
to the slew slender clones I've played
it's like a breath of fresh air and I'm
like legitimately apprehensive to move
forward this is so cool
who's there I have a camera
what's your picture taken only five
dollars five dollars I'll pay you four
dollars to go away I wonder why the
edges of my vision are getting more red
and Ron blood colored why is that I'm
gonna run now cuz I just discovered that
I can I'm a strong independent woman but
don't need no man or ghosts please go
away ghosts I don't need no ghosts how
am I supposed to look through my camera
Oh like that
hello hi go away please
why are you here are you still there yes
God
haha I took your picture I captured your
essence so my vision around my eyes go
red when a ghost is near ah I captured
your assets to do that right click the
mouse button then left click to take the
picture and capture that it goes inside
your magic camera ok so that was
something I still don't know exactly
where I'm going cuz it's hard to see
it's like really ridiculously hard to
see
so I've got one ghost and I'm assuming
that this is Japan or something along
those lines I think I just went down an
alley I don't not sure if there's
anything actually here but this was the
only way to go right wasn't it I think
yeah yeah it was there ghosty hear her
now anybody I'll just spend the rest of
the game like this ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
everything gets like permanently
brighter once I hit the hit the camera
button I like it I like it I can see
clearly now oh no it just cycles between
Lo and bright but I can see a little
better that's for sure wait is there
anything else here I'm not seeing
anything it's just as bamboo covered
grass I can't go in it huh I don't know
what the deal is but my ghost vision is
getting a little stronger in this area
oh hello whoa what the hell what no way
this game is awesome I serious I can
only see while I'm doing this so I'm
just gonna do this from now on
that way I'll be ready if a ghost wants
to get me oh ass dildo rang oh no this
isn't ship Japan what am I thinking it
was in the beginning it was some other
country when I I had to select a
language but I seem to have totally
forgotten what it was
hey stop that
hi stewpot you're my friend we close the
door it's rude not to hey why'd you come
back here I got a word to pick with you
hello-o ghosty where'd you go
go straight oh that is not good that
that is really disturbing on multiple
levels there's something on the wall
there that is really weird okay all
right good good good glad I saw that I'm
glad I came in here to envision that oh
hi hey buddy
looking good looking real good
lunch come closer come closer I'm gonna
take your picture oh you wait what's
going on hahahahahahahahaha
no not what you can't just take no for
you okay all right fine I'll follow you
then hey wait wait wait let's go down
this way or the other way what what did
I whoa stop opening the damn door close
that door
crafty where'd you go where did you run
off to little girl I have got a bone to
pick with you
oh it's locked
Oh piss I gotta go find the key which I
bet is gonna be upstairs all right let's
do this
Liz dues hello anybody here god I hope
not
Oh what was that
I saw something there nope everything
every one of my instincts is telling me
- nope out of here huh I don't want to
be here hi hi okay
got some nice pics of you ah ah they're
bigger don't you bigger you stupid ah
what
what uh how was that supposed to be and
now I'm dead great phantasmal let's go
this way I guess I guess I died I'm not
sure I'm not sure if that was part of
the game that I was supposed to do or if
I couldn't have beaten her anyway or as
after about as many times as I could
oh I'm back now
I think stop crying I don't like you I
don't want to be your friend you at the
end Erica you lady hang on let me
double-check the room maybe there was a
key on the ground or some I don't see
him in any worse for wear to being
nibbled on by a ghost
hey let me check these rooms first nice
bathroom how are you supposed to get
into that shower I don't know what a
weird toilet this whole place is weird
yeah you all need to shut up I hear
someone crying I heard someone laughing
just need to be quiet
wait where's crying come ah
no okay
good okay that's the first sensible
thing you've said oh now you have the
key to the main door good okay I will
take that and then I will run as far as
I can from this place goodbye forever
everybody it's been nice knowing you
okay is that a boat no that's a grave I
thought that was a boat or a jetski or
something
why if I'm trying to run away from
ghosts would I go straight into a
graveyard I do not know
okay wow what the hell is that oh my god
Oh Oh wowie Zowie holy balls my goodness
my spidey sense is tingling was what if
my what am I supposed to be looking at
here something is different oh wait hang
on
the candle flame something happened with
ya
hang on wait a minute the candle flame
goes out aha
wait what does that have to do with
anything what does that do
oh maybe it doesn't do anything maybe
it's a giant thing up there
I don't know what I'm supposed to be
looking for I know I'm supposed to be
looking for something but I don't see it
what am I looking for I don't think it's
actually the candle I think that's just
a graphical thing where occasionally
it'll turn off for the flash or
something I don't really know what I
don't know what I'm looking for I really
don't
okay so it's definitely in that area
that's where my glowy thing it's not the
big giant thing in the sky I really
don't know I really do not know there's
something here that I need to find with
my camera I just don't know what it is I
don't know I'm at a total loss I don't
know I really don't know I'm kind of
getting frustrated now cuz I'm not sure
what I'm supposed to do all right let's
go back I guess I got nothing else to do
I might as well go back try to see if I
miss something because I was literally
clicking my camera everywhere I could
and there was nothing nothing happening
what did I miss what am I missing
I don't know I don't know now there was
only one way to go through this through
this man graveyard thing wha wha
Oh what the hell holy crap can you not
die or something what the hell are you
did I kill you please tell me I did
hahaha what was that
how did it kind of look like the thing
hanging Olo we got more a bye
take some pictures yeah I'll teach you
this is uh this phone is pretty powerful
uh kind of surprising actually I seem
pretty calm I must have been through
this before
yeah ain't nothing like I said I'm a
strong independent woman who don't need
no man ever okay all three candles are
now lit aha oh hello oh ha ha ha ah end
of demo
okay all right there is the demo
remember the guys this was just a demo
but that looked incredible it was very
very very well done I'm very happy that
you know people independent developers
are getting into the horror genre
because it could really use some fresh
blood I mean when you think of like the
horror developers of today it's really
just frictional games and not many
others I mean there's also team size
killer the main creators of cry fear and
a lot of that like that the atmosphere
kind of reminded me of cry fear except a
lot slower paced I'm not saying slower
pace is bad but that was very good I'm
so happy to see something like different
and the whole fatal frame thing I need
to play fatal frame probably to
understand more about it because this
might have been inspired by it or
something along those lines but either
way awesome click the link in the
description to play for it yourself get
notified if when the full release is
released so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
ah
door
buzz
not